demi lovato is feeling confident
in their skin after shooting their very
first
sex scene for an upcoming project
demi took to their instagram yesterday
to share that along with the anxiety
they felt
from their first sex scene shoot they
also felt proud saying
had to film a sex scene today my first
one i had a little anxiety going into it
but the cast and crew were so
professional and easy to work with
it calmed me down immediately then i
thought about how proud i am for being
able to feel
comfortable enough in my skin to do that
i rarely ever showed my arms before
now i'm in this granted it barely shows
anything but still
yeah and they continued saying i don't
always feel good in my skin
so when i do and i feel sexy enough to
post
i do just that it's important to
celebrate
the little wins yay for this random
burst
of body confidence and yay for
hilarious and yay for awkward
hilarious sex
demi also shared some behind-the-scenes
pictures introducing us to their
character teddy
yes well there's teddy look at teddy i'm
excited to meet teddy i don't know what
this project is just yet but like i said
i have become such a huge fan
of demi lovato because i love what they
represent
and they are the most i would say one of
the most
open celebrities out there right now
talking about things
that are absolutely so important to talk
about you know
uh body positivity and mental health and
all of these things that they talk about
need to be talked about especially for a
generation
that looks up to someone like demi like
i am just
such a fan of them like in this last few
years and
who they have become like i'm blown away
to see
demi lovato today you know when you are
a fan of someone of an artist
like demi uh you connect with them
you share in a way their you know their
ups and downs
we've followed demi all throughout their
career
uh and for them to come out and say um
body positivity to say that they feel
confident right now to say that they
feel confident enough to post what they
posted
knowing what demi has been through in
throughout demi's entire career uh
that's something to celebrate
i got to talk about the the idea of
shooting the sexy every time i've
interviewed an actor about shooting a
sexy there's always that thing about how
awkward it can be depending on who is
there how awkward or how uncomfortable
it is
so i love demi's take on this
awkward hilarious sex thing that i guess
we'll get to see at some point in the
near future
and that for this being demi's very
first one it was a positive
experience yeah i mean
congrats to them for that we have some
comments here
as long carla says as long as demi is
taking care of herself
while working happy for her and that is
a good thing i
watched on demi lovato dancing with the
devil maybe
two times now because i am such a fan
um so she they are still you know
in the recovery phase and they
are working on themselves but i don't
think demi would be putting themselves
in any position where they feel
that it may affect their recovery
um and you know what sometimes doing
work
is part of recovery and putting yourself
back out there and doing what you love
to do
yeah absolutely that is so important and
to have the people around you
uh that will help you get to where you
need to go
i do want to point something out here
because it is important
demi's pronouns are they and them in an
earlier message
i said herself that was uh written by
one of our viewers but yes
you know there was also that great video
of
lizzo recently who uh took to a
paparazzi
about demi's pronouns and you know demi
responded in the best way i have lots of
friends who are
trans and non-binary and sometimes
people do slip and it's it's about
education
and um recognizing that people are
trying and
you know demi recognizes that it takes
time sometimes so yeah like let's
remember
demi's pronouns they and them um and
yeah i'm just so proud of them i don't
even know them but i am so proud of demi
i'm sure demi would be happy to know
that you feel this way absolutely